can I tell you about a new number so
it's a very scary numbers a bit evil its
bell figures prime okay so Bell forget
one of the seven princes of hell and the
reason is seven princes is because there
are seven deadly sins
he's also hell's ambassador to France I
didn't I didn't know how I'd had
ambassadors to different countries make
sure what the who house are busted to
England is right but anyway so what is
pelvic is a prime okay so let's say he
hasn't a bit one so this number here is
a bell figures prime so you can already
see the evil lurking within there right
number of the beef six six six six
square in the middle but it's even more
evil than this their team zeros on
either side of the 666 course their team
being classic I'm looking on there and
the other thing that's evil about this
is that there's actually thirty-one
digits and of course thirty one is
thirteen backwards isn't it so this is
this is a fundamentally evil number it's
one of a larger class of numbers which
are called the Bell figure numbers so a
bell figure number is basically anything
so B of n so the nth Bell figure number
is a one with n zeros 666 and then
another n zeroes and then a one okay so
any Bell figure number as this form you
want to be fancy about it and writer a
nice formula for it the formal eight you
would write is this is 10 to the n plus
3 plus 6 6 6 times 10 to the n plus one
plus one these are the Bell figure
numbers now the vast majority of them
and not prime okay so which ones are
prime well of course for N equals 13
it's a prime number because that's our
classic Bell figure prime N equals zero
is also a prime number so that's of
course this guy right and this is also
very this so this is another example of
a bell figure Prime and this is the
classic one but this is another one and
this is quite interesting as well
for other reasons
so this is the 1928 prime number okay so
this is a prime index and if you take
the numbers from here and add them
together so one plus six plus six four
six plus one
well that's 20 and you take these
numbers and you add them together like
one plus nine plus two plus eight well
that's also 20 so that's weird
okay that's that's okay well let's not
start we're gonna get more tenuous Brady
though so this is also this one here as
well this particular Bell figure prime
is also a Republican Prime a Republican
plot Prime is any number which is
essentially prime to the right okay so
it could be a Republican prime in
England supposed to be a Tory Prime okay
so it's prime to the right so you take
the right-hand side of the number not
count in the middle so in this case here
61 and that's a prime number so it's
kind of a coincidence that's I don't
know what it says about Donald Trump but
this Bell figure prior is also a
Republican primal will leave you to
speculate on that yes you do you do
that's of course if you take it to the
left yes because this is not an this is
clearly not a democratic frame because
16 is not not a prime number okay this
set of numbers these bell for good
numbers and the Bell figure Prime's were
discovered by the famous prime number
hunter Harvey Dubner who is basically
was an amateur number theorist he built
a massive computer in his garage with
his son and he just hunts for prime
numbers and this was one of the Ann's
axes that he shoved into his computer
and to see if he could find examples of
of prime numbers he came up with with
there with this one there are a few
others there are more obviously N equals
42 it is one which is pretty interesting
because that's of course the meaning of
life right n equals 506 is the next one
and there's a whole tower of these okay
are there an infinite number well we
don't know and the reason we definitely
don't know is because this is an example
of a palindromic prime so it obviously
looks the same forward backwards and we
don't know if there were an infinite
number of palindromic prime so we
certainly don't know there's an
infinite number of Bell figure primes
it's also a naughty prime obviously not
just because it's Bell figure it's an
Aussie Prime and nor C prime is one that
has more notes or zeros than any other
number and of course this example does
so it's a it's also an Aussie Prime
Northy prize yeah they're pretty cool
army
well it's lots of things it's a beastly
prime okay so a beastly prime is one
that has a six six six in it now this
one has it in a very special place right
in the middle right but a beastly prime
is one that has six six six so for
example another beastly prime is this
one six six six one two six six six nine
is a beastly prime there's all bunch of
these as well as loads of these beastly
primary think with with 666 in it we're
not finished yet if you want to know
even more about this evilness check out
the extra video on numberphile - this is
I think quite scary as well and this one
hasn't got a name as far as I know and
they'll be a bit of a twist I didn't
want this to be all about evil right so
I thought we should try to redress the
balance with a very good but if you'd
like to know more about six-six-six
itself of course we've done a video
about that in the past check out links
on the screen and down in the video
description
[Music]